a win for the nationalists shin fein as
opinion polls predict would make history
in northern ireland it up ends a century
of dominance by parties dedicated to the
union with great britain putting on top
a republican party that exists to forge
a united ireland
that isn't going to happen imminently
and many voters were swayed instead by
more immediate concerns
oh united ireland's on the cards no
doubt about it like oh no that's
important to me yeah and what do you
think they'll achieve since
i think we'll keep up with us for you
we'll get equal rates we'll get better
housing better hospitals
so that's just
a tuition game open game
shin fame was once the political face of
the irish republican army that waged a
decades-long conflict with the british
army and pro-british loyalist
paramilitaries
its electoral success will have struck
fear into the hearts of many unionists
who already feel marginalized by
westminster's handling of brexit
negotiations with the eu
and a new trade border in the irish sea
that they say undermines northern
ireland's place within the united
kingdom
they need to get a wake-up call now
nobody wants a shin fear minister uh
the unionist people don't want to
sympathy and minister because first
first first and foremost if we have it
then you're going to call for a border
pole and there's no doubt about that
there's even a question mark over
whether the democratic unionist party
leader will take up his position as
deputy first minister behind shin feins
michelle o'neal
jeffrey donaldson says he wants the sea
border protocol removed first
in northern ireland symbolism matters
hugely so while power sharing enshrined
in the good friday peace agreement
ensures that the positions of first
minister and deputy first minister
shared between the largest unionist and
nationalist parties have exactly equal
powers the changing of places in the
stormont assembly in this election
carries enormous symbolic weight
unionism is in a very uncertain place
northern ireland had its centenary last
year but the celebrations were rather
muted um there was a sense of the future
of the union very much being at stake
and partly because of
brexit and what's that that means for
northern ireland change relationships
between northerland and the rest of the
uk as a result of the withdrawal
agreements and the protocol um but also
what's going on within unionism itself
it's very fragmented
and with that fragmentation comes deep
uncertainty over political stability in
the short term and longer term questions
about the future of northern ireland
itself jonah hull al jazeera belfast